i've looked you up and i've
um seen what you do for a living you
know we're not going to state it here
because i don't want to dox you but
you're obviously a clever woman you know
you've been through school and
university you probably make decent
money
um are you married you have kids like
where are you in your life right now
because you said that you're a 32 year
old woman but i didn't get much more
from you aside from that
i'm in a long-term relationship okay and
how's that going for you
really really good okay and why are you
coming to my videos in my book if it's
going really really good because most of
the time whenever i'm talking to women
it's not
um i want to
understand the world beyond just me well
in terms of me
i'm just like trying to figure out the
things that motivate me
like i i feel like they're not
completely the same as if i were a man
doing the things that i was doing i i
well i it's a little bit uh complicated
to explain
um i'm also like just fascinated with
you
and watching your videos so um i've kind
of
been on a roll with watching a lot of
your videos so what about my content
fascinates you
um the red pill ideology fascinates me
and the way you personally presented
and the way roller does as well it's uh
like uh
you you you you totally believe what
you're saying and you're not coming from
a hateful place and you seem completely
reasonable and like you seem like
somebody that somebody like like that i
can disagree with you and still
talk to you about this and i was curious
where this conversation would lead
oh and something else i really wanted to
bring up um do you know alexander grace
yes i've heard of him okay uh so um
there was a video that he made once
where like
like two years ago where he was asking
the question
of can the red pill ideology go too far
and he was saying he would like
to have that conversation with somebody
like rolo or like you
and then you responded as in like okay
let's let's uh
let's possibly talk about this like it
seemed like uh you guys were setting up
to have a video about
that and like i think he would be a much
better debater
and much more comfortable doing that on
youtube than i would
and that never happened and i'm curious
why not because i think that would be
great
i never got an invite from him to talk
about anything okay it was part of the
video
so and perhaps he didn't email you but
uh
that's something i would like to see
maybe other people would like to see
that as well
i could send you the video into talking
to other people about different ideas i
mean
i always tell tell guys and i've been
more vocal about a lot more lately and i
was like if you have a better solution
to something that i've talked about
then let me know what it is right i mean
is there something that you disagree
with me on categorically like is there
something that's offside because i'm
because i'm trying to get my head around
the origin of the email right
i disagree with the fact that uh what
you've
like everything you believe about women
i'm sure it's true to some extent
you seem to believe it's true
predominantly and i don't know
what that's based on okay so what's not
true that i've said then so why don't we
start with that
so so so basically uh you
feel that women
in general like they're always uh like
even when they're settled in a
relationship married so on
that it seems like you're saying that
most of them like 99
of them or more are always open to the
bigger
better deal so they're not truly like
they're not really um committed for life
they're not truly loyal
well correct i mean uh you read my book
so i mean you got the
the piece of data from it where um i was
talking about how
they collected surveys from women on
backup plans
and more than 50 percent of women in
relationships
have a back-up plan ready to go if their
marriage doesn't work out
so uh it could be the marriage could not
work out for a variety of reasons
the their husband could break up with
them um
they can come to a place like women
leave marriages like 80 90 percent of
the time it's not men leaving women it's
women leaving men though
okay so if you look at the divorce
filing stats it's it's women that are
the plaintiffs that are
initiating the these actual divorces
with men it's not men leaving women
so we're looking at the united states
and canada right yeah and
i'm not saying 100 of women are going to
act all the time but on a balance of
probabilities if
if they have the opportunity to uh move
from one guy to another guy that's a
better choice
and there's not going to be a lot of
collateral damage women are
more likely than men to do that very
very quickly and very easily without
remorse you know at whatever expense you
know
comes at the dude's cost okay so do you
think
that uh the thought process that leads
them to leaving the guy
is like something not not bad
like from their point of view it's not
bad intentions from their point of view
it's something that they want
and then they they come up with a reason
why the person they're with is a bad
person and like truly believe that do
you think that's what happens
well i'll put it to you this way when i
don't care who the guy is i mean if he's
straight
okay if he's walking down the street and
there's a gorgeous woman walking the
other way with giant boobs he's going to
look at her
okay that's what men do
in fact women will probably do the same
thing too because it stands out
you know but the fact remains that women
are hypergamous men are not that doesn't
mean all women are going to leave
like i said earlier in the cast i don't
know if you heard it when i was reading
your email but
um one of the things my colleague said
back in the early days of before the
train wreck
sean smith would often talk about how he
saw women in his clinical practice
jumped through tremendous hoops like
heroic hoops
to try to save the marriage and one of
the things that i followed up with him
to challenge that a little bit was
okay how how did these women look
you know if they were married for 12
years and they had three kids were they
attractive
did they become obese did they have the
option to leave the marriage did they
have the final you know the
financial resources leave the marriage i
knew one couple
um this is about eight or nine years ago
they were a friend of of this woman that
i was dating
and her husband was clinically depressed
all the time like he would go upstairs
and lock himself in a room and never
leave
and like she hated it okay she was she
was so pissed off being in that marriage
she was so let down she was expecting so
much more but she didn't have the
ability to leave that
marriage because one they didn't have
any money two she was not attractive
at all like she was she was at the
bottom of the
uh sexual marketplace so she so she
never left you know she just put up with
it
so she has to have the capacity in my
view
to be able to leave that and move to
something better
so that's that's an underlying notion of
hypergamy but it's just
it's just there you know it's it's it's
part of the firmware with women
okay do you think what men do an
equivalent thing
like um in terms of like if they have an
opportunity
i guess um to either cheat
or just get divorced to move up to a
higher socio-economic status like women
tend to bang
up on the social economic scale men
men never like pick women based on their
uh success like i said in my book men
are success objects women are beauty
objects right so
men will sleep with beautiful women it
doesn't matter how much money she makes
it doesn't matter like
he could be making five 500 000 a year
and he'll get with a 40 000
year hairdresser like they don't they
don't make distinctions but
a 40 000 a year hairdresser is gonna
want
that rich guy she's not going to want to
be with the guy that's on welfare okay
uh do you think that yeah yeah i see
what you're saying us do you think for
most men given the opportunity
to cheat on their wives their ltr's
retreat
um most men given well men's sexual
strategy is unlimited access to
unlimited women so why wouldn't they
cheat
okay so you feel i'm not saying that
they all would but that's what they want
yeah well i guess you just put men and
women on like the same uh
moral level with me like the guys uh
like the the women given the opportunity
you think
to get a bigger better deal would go for
the bigger better deal and the guys
given the opportunity
to cheat which would devastate the
person the woman that they're with
well men and women cheat for different
reasons you know what the reasons are
right
though women cheat in order to find a
guy to
uh to to be their next person
okay well okay why don't we handle it
this way like men and women get jealous
for different reasons
did you know that yes and
what are the reasons that they get
jealous for uh so
a man would get jealous if his woman
sleeps with somebody
actually has sucks for them and a woman
would get jealous if her
man has an emotional attachment to
somebody do you know why that is
evolutionary reasons a man wants to make
sure
that the kids are his and the woman
wants to make sure she holds on to the
resources
good so we're getting somewhere so you
understand that there are distinct
differences between men and women
in the sexual strategies right okay so
we're not really in disagreement you're
just saying you know things that
you've that you've drawn conclusions on
because you don't like the way that i
talk about certain ideas or the way that
i conclude certain chapters in my book
right
i mean i'm trying to understand you well
there's
nothing complicated about i mean i could
take the book and call it the unplugged
check
and make it pink but the information in
the book would still be the same
okay
you